three McCrory here Michael brush go
Anjali and Here I am in Nashville
Tennessee at the adventure Science
Center Madisonville Tennessee at Sally
Knox vineyard so we are at the Wilton
County Fair here in Lebanon Tennessee
here at NatGeo and Washington DC
Nashville is the largest city in the
path of totality so we are so excited to
have that one minute and 50 seconds of
totality this afternoon I am so thrilled
to get a chance to see something as
beautiful and as magnificent as little
so many places that's why you before get
to be frank
the party has started
everybody's got their glasses a lot of
fun they got ice cream they've got
cupcakes going on good day to be working
at magia okay so we are here they are
playing total eclipse of the Sun and it
just dropped at least a few degrees it's
getting colder it's getting darker and
we can only see a little sliver of the
Sun now is pretty easy I know my little
Orion what is this Oh almost almost
okay totality just happened the Sun is
rising again essentially it went dark
here as you can see from the videos and
this massive cloud blocks the whole list
so we missing the corona we missing the
diamond ring so if we heard the birds
come out we watched a 360 sunset and
and now the Sun is rising again I just
saw my first total solar eclipse and it
was awesome words can't describe it it
was deeply beautiful amazing so highly
recommend
[Music]
you